we've been talking about this all week
obviously the country right now has been
consumed by it and I think a lot of us
are still in shock I know personally I
am but I guess it's finally time for all
of us to just accept the new reality
that Dwayne the rock Johnson has been
named People magazine's sexiest man it's
over it's over it's over you got
accepted it's over they've decided and
it's time to move on and of course as
part of a time-honored tradition there
is something I must now do well total a
client is about to deliver a concession
speech after losing two new sexy man
elect Wayne the rock Johnson we joined
Conan now at his election night
headquarters first of all I want to
congratulate the winner our opponent the
rock let's get here for the rock
[Applause]
I know you were cheering by mostly
booing after they held up the boo sign
but we have to accept he won fair and
square
we fought a long hard sexy battle for
this election I really feel I put in the
work this year I've been eating right
just absolutely blasting my pecs whaling
on my quads and I introduced two new
sexy faces this one and this one I'd
like to thank my interns who agreed to
stand behind me and look sad thank you
for doing that
you are overdoing it and I especially
want to thank my running mate Andy
Richter Andy bravely stood by my side
this whole time I thought I've always
felt that this whole thing was stupid
and sad
[Applause]
thank you Andy in the end I just didn't
have the votes as you can see it was a
very tight race but a few key states
ended up going the other way I want to
thank the good people of Misquamicut
Rhode Island for their tireless support
[Applause]
they know quality I'm proud of the
campaign I ran though I can't shake the
feeling that this whole system was
rigged against me
especially after WikiLeaks released this
unsexy photo of me eating very hot soup
that did not help could have cost me the
election but I'm not going to stop
fighting I promise 2017 will be my
sexiest year yet tighter pants various
elective surgeries and I'm going to
start buying top-shelf cologne instead
of making my own can we do it
sex weekend
[Applause]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
you